[Music]
what was the most fun you guys had on
set
[Music]
working with you everyone definitely
liked the food it for me seeing everyone
in the costumes doing all these fun I
didn't really do any like hand-to-hand
combat or anything like I was just like
like 20 feet away shooting these
fireballs but I was throwing it fun for
me yeah with the CGI and everything I
love shooting the open a my opening
scene that was a lot of fun we just
improvised and rift a bunch on that so
we had a good time but I also you know I
trained a lot for the action sequences
and the training was pretty tough but
then when it came down to being able to
like perform on set it was really really
wonderful to have had this sort of the
foundation and - I had a lot of fun
doing the action stuff because even
though it's fate you still feel really
powerful you get really it do it you
know - like grunt did make sounds and
like you really gonna feel it's it's a
cool it's very powerful which was fun
Julian last night you said you're really
influenced by tyka yep who is you
directed you and your first film yeah
hum for the one people on my side
actually your third yeah um do you think
you guys would reach him again now that
you're both part of the Marvel Universe
allele of - cuz he's working on a film
at the moment yeah of course he is oh
but yeah I'd love to
absolutely yeah he was so influential
like to my humor and he sort of like
shaped me as an actor so it was really
cool I would love to work with them
again do who do you think we've been in
a battle of tigers Thor character quirk
or fire fist I don't know I'd love to
see that black and another interview I'd
love to see them like team-up yeah like
if you know there'd be a really peril
well they could find each other probably
fought for us to be honest it's true
I feel like this film sets be hot rocks
I feel like this film sets up the
possibility of a x-force movie if are
you guys find out how made for evil
what kind of well I was waiting for a
jerk like that if they like would put
them in a do cuz we did that before a
black panther came out we're like X for
sex and then as soon as my pants I came
out I was like no no it's what conduct
that's true mm-hmm whatever you can do
the fire fist X first yeah are you guys
signed up for that kind of a filament
would it have the same tone instead
polar be a little different do you think
well neither of us have seen any script
nor do I think one is written I liked
last a year ago Ryan was like this is
this may happen because that was also a
year ago and I think it also really
depends on sort of the reception of the
characters and if this movie and seeing
people want more of and what they don't
want more of I am signed on for three
more movies with Fox not necessarily
sequels oh yeah it's me as well I have
no idea I would love for a father
spin-off if there was ever one Atlanta
your ear Atlanta co-star Donald Glover
it also has a big film coming out with
yeah these films my god I haven't seen
hits he's running around we were both
running around doing press stuff right
now so I just got like two days ago from
Europe he's in LA and I think
everybody's so secretive that they
wouldn't let anybody else you can move
his better and some clothes do but I'm
super excited to Rio I think it would be
I think it would be fun I'm super happy
room now Julian you were too young to
see the original version I mean it like
on Mouse
yeah bunny I only swore like a few weeks
ago oh really I'm the cutout digit big
six montage enough uh-huh how much
potatoes
yes I sort of was that very put here
shooting it with everything seeing the
person huh was that part machine
I saw snippets of it but um I sort of
like Russell sort of just he's designed
little thing so it was kind of easy for
me okay
yeah are you nervous at all about any
family members moms auntie's definitely
my aunt definitely my aunties really
like my grandmother I am so scared for
them to them what sure um I'm really
nervous expecially on my cousin I
already know they're gonna be low cuz I
got a big family um I think it's how
many is it Christian like 44 fit yeah
like 50 51 first cousins so your how are
you guys really brothers twin your
mother and brother your twin brother Leo
both born in 2002 on October the 26th oh
my god he's pretty cool have you seen
the film yeah we saw it last night was
your reaction it's real hard to tell
what he's like isn't through hard to
tell what he's like as an actor because
I only see him as Julian yeah I can tell
he's acting he seemed real wouldn't am I
feel same yeah it is I that's the one
thing I wouldn't like I don't I don't
like I don't really get like like super
emotional around family only some
survivors are you so good that's so good
in that scene yeah let's you're like
Angry might mmm ah tell us a secret
about Julian a secret about Julian are
saying it before he sleeps with six
pillows and I have none like the pace
feels me so I told he would have told my
like deepest darkest oh really yeah I
have one in front of me uh-huh I'm two
behind me wonderfully me to behind me at
least to like there I can sleep on I
make a nest I'm a bird I'm kind of like
that you actually don't like sleeping on
the pill but I like having like a like I
like having it just on the edge it's not
sort of like
yeah I'm not gonna wake up we listening
oh my god lastly Avengers versus X force
who do you think would win in a battle
well they're like 89 Avengers yeah so
then you're lucky yeah you're right I
reserve I'd be the only one who support
it somehow no dude pool or something you
be the mother you take that out time and
Josh could be both at the same time
that'd be wearing my body like cable
versus that like if he puts the Infinity
governmental Nizam his whole arm Tunes
golden or something yeah he's got the
Infinity Gauntlet and then he's got like
the room cyborgs are and they're just
like you know oh my god who is winning
that like
[Music]
[Applause]